Let's get back to the HTTP request.
We need to specify some additional
details that are essential
before establishing
the network connection.
So far the HttpUrlConnection object only
contains the destination we want for
this request, we still need to define
the action that the server should
perform on the request.
This is expressed using one of the HTTP
verbs we described earlier such as GET
or POST.
The next step is to make sure you
set the desired HTTP method which
allows you to be explicit about what
exactly want to do with HTTP connection.
There are few common HTTP method types
or actions that you should be aware of.
When we're getting information
to be return to us.
The best method to use is GET.
There are several
methods to use in HTTP.
Well get is the most commonly used
option, POST is also frequently used
when you need to update some information
on a server such as when you update
a blog post or you're entering billing
information or shopping online.
In other words,
a GET request is typically
reading information from the server and
sending it back to the client.
Well a POST request is generally
contains information to be written to
the server.
Check out the list and
notes for links and
where you can learn more about
the various other HTTP methods.
For example,
when you enter a URL into a web browser,
a GET request containing the destination
URL is generated and sent to the server.
This request also contains a header
section which includes metadata
about the request.
This includes things like
what types of languages and
encodings the client can accept,
an information about
the client has operating system
in the screen dimensions.
Mobile apps do the exact same thing,
when they are requesting
information from a server.
So how do you know what request
method to set, while you can check
the documentation for the given
API they are using to confirm it.
Each API endpoint should be explicitly
documented with a HTTP action required.
It should be consistent with the GET and
POST behavior we explained earlier
in cases where no action is
specified GET is typically assumed.
For example,
let's go back to the Twitter public API.
There are many endpoints provided
to fetch information about users,
tweets, friends or account information.
Twitter specifies up front whether
any of these endpoints are GET or
POST requests.
Let's click on this API endpoint
which let's us get the most recent
tweets posted by a user.
If I scroll down a bit I
can find the resource URL
where we can make the HTTP request.
And GET is the HTTP request
method type because we're
reading the existing tweets
from the Twitter server.
There are many other examples where we
make GET requests to get the list of
direct messages or
lists of friends from a user.
On the other hand, if we want to
write new data to the Twitter server,
we need to use a POST request.
The API endpoint allows us
to point to a new tweet.
Just to make a connection to a new
URL and specify the POST method type.
Remember that if you make a POST request
you need to send the new
data along as well.
In this case,
the message text for a new tweet.
POST is used when you're writing to
the server, which means you're creating,
deleting, or updating an entity.
This will make the new information
available to other clients
when they perform a GET request for
the latest Tweets.
Here's another quick example,
the Instagram API.
These endpoints allow you to
get information about a user or
the images or video files that
they recently posted or liked.
All of these requests are reading
information from the server so
they are all GET requests.
On the other hand, the Instagram
comments API allows you to get or
modify the comments on POST.
Here you can see the request
method type is GET, POST or DEL.
Sometimes you'll see
DEL as its own action,
whereas POST will be for
creating a comment.
DEL is for deleting a comment.
Sometimes all of this behavior is
combined in a general POST request that
handles any type of modification
on the server data.
It just depends on how
the API was built.
For a list of all the API request
methods, see the link below.
But for the purposes of this course,
we just want you to become comfortable
with the distinction between GET verses
POST, or reading from verses
writing to the web server.